nous vous présentons aujourd'hui
l'essayiste icab est ici au canada
rachida azdouz qui est psychologue
spécialiste des relations
interculturelles pas multiculturelle
mais interculturel grande différence je
mange une et elle vient nous présenter
son nouveau livre qui à un titre qui va
vraiment un ça va nous ça va brasser là
ça va brasser tout le monde commençait
du tout quel est ce titre louis d'où il
part une part de quelque chose note est
quelque chose qui était pas beau au
départ vous vouliez c'est comme ça
devenait mais on accepte d'aller crever
quelque chose rachid
je suis en fait le bonjour tout le monde
d'abord et moi aussi je veux du chocolat
donc le titre de mon laissez le vivre
ensemble et pas rs bouche comme son nom
l'indiqué on se gargarise beaucoup avec
cette expression là bas d'ailleurs pas
seulement ici chez nous au québec et au
canada mais partout en europe et
ailleurs même dans des pays émergents
zoubair vous contredirai pas et donc je
voulais un petit peu prendre à bras le
corps ce concept là ah non pas avec la
prétention d'en donner une définition
figée et scientifique
d'ailleurs je me dégage assez rapidement
de toute prétention scientifique parce
que c'est un essai donc c'est un point
de vue subjectif mais ce n'est pas un
point de vie frivole parce que c'est
quand même le point de vue d'une
observatrice sedin actrices de la
semaine interculturelle donc que je fais
depuis 20 ans plus de 25 ans maintenant
mais c'est un essai et
je prends cette expression la vivre
ensemble et je la tourne dans tous les
sens je la déshabille jma décortique
pour faire ressortir les différentes
conceptions et les différentes
définitions parfois contradictoires qui
sous tendent cette même expression donc
comme on ne parle pas tous de la même
chose il va de soi que ça se termine en
foire d'empoigné
oui écoutez avant d'en arriver au cas
précis avant d'assassiner tout le monde
on va présenter des images de ce nouveau
livre pour que les gens une image là ça
aide à mieux comprendre je pense et on
va voir aussi notre webmestre du côté
français avant qu'elles soient en
vacances
marie claude qui a tourné cette petite
vidéo pour nous la vidéo numéro 2
présentation du livre de rachida qui
vous allez voir donc si vous cherchez ce
en librairie ce sera facile à repérer
ces rouges avec la belle photos de
rachida et ensuite on a ajouté on a
ajouté des images du bureau à radio
canada international des gens qui
consultent le livre qui le livre ou qui
le lie son sable à dire nous on l'a lu
un il ya raymond des bateaux qui l'a lu
et je les lui donc vous êtes vous en
faites pas on sait de quoi il est
question aujourd'hui
alors voilà c'est une scène amusante on
voit jamais ça des gens au travail à
radio-canada et à radio canada
international part de loin et on voit
ici
marie claude sénécal qui elle feuillette
le livre bien sûr et puis une beaucoup
de plaisir il ya aussi une autre
collègue la station espagnole vous allez
voir à l'arrière qui a beaucoup de
plaisir pas grand chose à faire
et voilà très drôle une scène de la vie
quotidienne
maintenant pour la scène de la vie
quotidienne au québec qu'on va se
retourner vers rachid à rachida vous
disiez que vous aviez pas le point de
vue d'un spécialiste mais quand même
vous êtes psychologue et vous avez je
pense vous en vous regardez la société
on va dire québécoise avec l'oeil du
docteur qui dia qui a un problème ou une
maladie yann ça ne fonctionne pas et
c'est peut-être vraiment récemment
consent rencontre et pas seulement au
québec mais ailleurs dans le monde que
ça devient évident mais à quel moment
vous avez ça faisait commence à vous
dire les gens veulent vraiment peut-être
pas vivre ensemble vous êtes posé la
question est ce qu'on veut vraiment
vivre ensemble oui
je dis pas c'est pas un point de vue de
spécialistes parce que je me positionne
quand même comme spécialistes parce que
c'est mon champ d'expertisé les
relations interculturelles mais je dis
que c'est pas c'est pas un livre
scientifique
donc c'est pas aimé ça reste quand même
académique le bon donc j'ai commencé à
me poser la question à partir de ma
propre expérience comme comme analyste
et comme pédagogue surtout c'est qu'à
partir du moment où j'ai pris acte de
l'impasse dans laquelle elle est plongée
depuis longtemps déjà et ceux qui
n'aiment pas ce qui ne fait que ce
plafond ne voit pas l'issue
c'est la polarisation du débat sur le
vivre ensemble et c'est dans ce sens là
que je me pose la question avant de
continuer à polémiquer sur le comment
vivre ensemble c'est à dire quel modèle
privilégié le multi l'inter
l'assimilationnisme il faut que
peut-être s'arrêter il se posait la
question avons nous réellement envie de
vivre ensemble et là c'est peut-être un
peu mon biais de psychologues parce que
je pars toujours de l'individu je prends
l'exemple du couple je dirais une coupe
peut très bien entamé une thérapie de
couple mais s'il est des deux n'a pas
envie de continuer la vie en commun il
entame une thérapie de couples que pour
1 mais l'autre a accepté que le couple
est fini il faut arrêter là et il faut
que le terrain peu de vous mettre dehors
et vous disent 'vous devriez peut-être
aller voir un avocat ou un juge mais je
ne peux rien pour vous alors c'est un
peu ce qui arrive dans le débat le débat
est très polarisée il est pris en otage
par l'extrême gauche et l'extrême droite
et je renvoie dos à dos les deux
postures de deux positions parce que les
deux sont dans des dérives et des excès
qui disent effectivement le refus de
vivre ensemble et ce qui était très
pervers sait que ça se fait au nom du
vivre ensemble
oui donnez moi l'exemple parce que ça
commence comme ça le livre par des
exemples vous êtes invités à des débats
vous vous apercevez qu'il s'agit en fait
de faux débat on veut faire semblant
d'avoir des débats mais au fond c'est
parce qu'on veut c'est parce qu'on
cherche c'est ce qu'on cherche et
d'ailleurs je relate de plusieurs
expériences que j'ai moi-même vécu soit
comme panélistes donc comme experts
invités soit comme modératrice de
situation je me suis retrouvé à modérer
un débat qui n'en était pas un parce que
tous les panélistes défendent est le
même point de vue et le public était
conquis donc c'était plutôt la star
academy je dois dire que la véritable
débat sur vivre ensemble et encore et
encore la star academy il ya des gens
qui défendent un point de vue de faire
un candidat au bureau qu'à l'autre dit
que sa photo donc c'est un des exemples
que je relate l'autre exemple c'est les
contradictions
c'est à dire de vouloir revendiquer pour
soi le droit à toutes les différences
mais de le nier à l'autre denis et à
l'autre le droit de revendiquer aussi sa
spécificité c'est tout oui c'est tout
sept autres ça peut être aussi
l'accueillant la société d'accueil à
laquelle parfois dans notre désir de
défendre un point des minoritaires et
présumé nra blonde yago ont dit à
l'autre mais toi tu es toi tu es déjà
dominant tout c'est comment dirais-je
tous ces éclairages et tous ses angles
que je sens délégitimer aucun l'ombre le
seul point de vue que je délégitime
c'est le point de vue violent mais
haineux mais les autres points de vie
faut les écouter il faut les entend
j'adore votre façon de présenter ces
situations parce que vous démolit
démolissez tous les cas vous voulez de
bouder construisent et la faire pour
nous montrer à tous que peu importe nos
opinions parce que c'est pas eu ce n'est
pas l'opinion que vous condamnez c'est
la façon d'arriver à l'opinion ou de
battre m de quoi se protéger
c'est le procédé on a préparé des
petites vidéos des petites surprises
mais pour moi aussi ce sera des
surprises parce que je me souviens plus
de quoi il s'agit pas grave vous allez
voir on va découvrir sa numéro 3 cette
série de vos écrits de votre livre et ça
nous amène à une réflexion
ça prend toujours cette seconde à voir
quand on arrive au but c'est que c'est
plus long que voilà on finit par devoir
vous la voyez vidéo on finit par perdre
de vue le sens même du débat le débat se
transforme en objet de combat c'est ce
que vous avez écrit
vous vous reconnaissez j'espère et puis
il j'ai pas si on ajoute une autre
citation non mais c'est bien je ce que
je ce que je remarque c'est que vous
dites
on a tous une responsabilité ici à
essayer d'avoir une vraie conversation
avec celui que quel on n'est pas
d'accord mais vous passez en revue les
délais les différents scénarios où on
pourrait assumer une plus grande
responsabilité
les médias 1 la famille l'éducation
et puis je vous avoue aussi un discours
sur des opinions par rapport à ceux qui
disent représenter les personnes
minoritaires et des fameux directeur
directrice d'organisation ils sont
arrivés à un moment donné ils ont saisi
l'occasion et puis la boit dix ans plus
tard on subit encore l'opinion
enfin jeu mais j'ai pas vu dans votre
livre
quoi que ce soit de rassurant parce que
je me trompe
non pas du tout d'abord oui si vous
parlez des leaders autoproclamés que je
que je que je condamne parce que il
participe au bruit ambiant sans
nécessairement offrir deux propositions
oui la dimension rassurant elle est dans
l étang d'humour avec lequel j'ai choisi
d'aborder tout ça parce qu'il ya deux
choses très importantes
d'une part un choix préconscient je ne
me place pas au dessus de la mêlée c'est
à dire que quand je dénonce la
polarisation
je dénonce ma propre lâcheté en tant que
personnes qui participent au débat
public
la lâcheté des fois de ne pas dire
certaines choses je dénonce ma propre
auto censure ne pas dire certaines
choses pour ne pas être récupéré par un
camp ou par l'autre ne pas être récupéré
par les xénophobes et l'extrême droite
ne pas être récupéré par la droite
religieuse
donc je me place tout de suite dedans
comme une actrice pas seulement une
observatrice
mais aussi une actrice qui a ses proches
lâcheté et qui par son silence des fois
contribuer à la colorisation
la deuxième chose c'est vous dites est
ce que expire quelque chose de restera
donc je n'apporte pas de réponse mais je
rassure dans le sens où je dis il ya
beaucoup de barbie en citant ce n' est
qu' il faut il faut séparer les choses d
du bruit qu'elles font il ya beaucoup de
bruit autour de ce débat mais le bruit
il est surtout en haut chez les leaders
autoproclamés parce que c'est leur fond
de commerce
oui ça va mal et donc et et les
politiciens parce que la question
identitaire est devenue un enjeu
électoral
mais sur le terrain dans la vraie vie ça
va plutôt bien et là je pars du québec
et du canada je ne parle pas de l'europe
ça va relativement bien mais savons plus
nier les problèmes il ya des problèmes
et des incompatibilités
il ya des gars de la crispation
identitaire de part et d'autre autant
chez les accueillants que j'ai les
accueillis mais je pense mon optimisme
il est plutôt là de dire tu entends qu
il y a encore des relations entre les
gens tant qu'on n'a pas encore de
ghettos parce qu'on peut pas parler à
proprement peut pas à proprement parler
de ghettos au québec il y à quelques
concentration ethnique ici et là on n'a
pas omis loin du scénario à la française
donc je pense que l'optimisme il est là
et dans dans la la la la je parle du
mariage mixte par exemple un moment
donné dans les enfants de mariages
mixtes ne peuvent pas détester leur père
ou leur mère ils vont être obligés de
les concilier ces identités là et je
suis pas du tout dans le la logique
bisounours on s'aime on s'embrasse tout
va bien au contraire ce que je dis c'est
que vivre ensemble c'est aussi prendre à
bras le corps les conflits les nommés ne
pas léser les esquiver son prétexte que
et c'est dans ce sens là que pour faire
aussi le multiculturalisme mais prétend
l'éloge de la différence suffit à tout
régler ouais ouais il ya les aliciens
c'est très fort
écoutez suberbe ce que vous connaissez
pas la formule favori leur vous
expliquez vous avez doit poser des
questions à l'invité de la semaine
ouais et je pense que vous êtes un
tout à fait bien placés pour le faire
malheureusement je n'ai pas encore lu
votre livre mais je suis vraiment j'ai
hâte de le lire mais j'ai une question
comme ça qui me vient rapidement
commandé que déconstruire
cette polarisation sais pas comment vous
voyez même si vous condamnez votre
lâcheté mais malgré que ce qui me
l'acheter c'est pas une lâcheté que vous
vouliez ne s'est pas assumer mais quand
même mais c'est pas on arrive parfois
dans des situations où on ne peut pas
carrément se mouiller comme on y soit
pour des raisons professionnelles soit
pour des raisons me dit ah ah ce que
c'est vraiment ça voilà ten carrément de
ce2 ce2 carrément de dire le fond de
notre pensée
comment être plus ou moins efficaces
pour déconstruire en tant que tel
intellectuel mais en tant que citoyenne
lenteur oui merci beaucoup c'est pas la
question je sens sa discrétion venez
vous d'europe 1 ont battu les bleus
tunisie tunisie bon alors donc le la
façon dont je procède pour déconstruire
moi je suis aussi jeunes gens c'est une
bonne chose d'avoir à affronter un
pédagogue
donc ce que je fais c'est que je sous
forme de dialogue je je je n'invente un
dialogue entre les deux camps et en
permettant à chacun des deux et parfois
c'est moi l'autre camp c'est moi c'est
moi la paix d'abord devant un de mes
étudiants au wynn de mes étudiantes qui
me dit des choses qui sont parfois très
dures parfois très raciste ou parfois
pourrait représenter raciste et je
réponds donc c'est de permettre aux deux
parce que dans la vraie vie ça se passe
pas comme ça dans la vraie vie mode
chanel qui parle et qui dit des choses
qu'on n'a pas envie d'entendre
on le bayonne pour le bailleur est donc
là j'essaie d'enlever le bâillon et à
travers ses dialogues de permettre aux
deux positions de s'exprimer sans être
interrompu et donc ça permet en même
temps de dire regardez quand vous
laisser les gens parler mais des fois il
nuance eux mêmes leurs propres propos et
des fois quand les propos sont carrément
polarisée et qui a aucune rencontre
possible
ça permet aux gens qui vont me lire de
se voir dans le miroir et de dire voilà
ce que ça donne quand vous monologuer
chacun de votre côté
arc bouté sur une posture qui maquille
dit le vivre ensemble mais qui en même
temps l'empêchent ben voilà ce que ça
donne
le miroir grossissant de votre
polarisation le relais ce que ça donne
c'est dans ce sens
cela que je le dis quand à quant à la
lâcheté je perds de l'acheter je parle
aussi d'autres raisons qui peuvent nous
amener à nous taire c'est des fois
justement se taire c'est la meilleure
solution
parce que ça il ne faut pas ajouter aux
bruits ambiants
parce que soit ça devient juste un
murmure que personne n'entend donc c'est
totalement inutile ou ça donne de
l'importance à des positions bruyante
mais minoritaire alors quand vous vous
jeter dans la foule et que vous ajoutez
votre voix vous ne fait qu'alimenter
cette spirale stérile et cette
rhétorique stérile donc se tait et
parfois le fait dû l'acheter mais aussi
le fait d'un pragmatisme
permettez moi de rebondir sur un point
par exemple exemple tu voles en alaska
il ya un double au début de l'année je
pense qu on a commencé à parler du la
campagne du racisme systémique et tout
un bureau 8 août 1 et tout un scandale
qui carrément kiki à carrer pu et qui a
éclaté sur le terme systémique et ce qui
a poussé des politiciens a carrément re
rétropédaler est carrément on ne leur en
veux plus parler on veut plus parler de
racisme et systémique parce que par
crainte que sous la pression
je dirais surtout médiatique et le prêt
d'une pression populaire comme quoi on
taxe la société québécoise de racisme
mais c'est la même c'est les mêmes pour
les deux siens qui ont mis ces mots là
dans les champs puis après ils se sont
rendu compte que ça marchait pas bien
qu'ils ont essayé de l'enlever et
comment est ce qu'on fait en tant que
société pour éviter que les partis
politiques iep rennes 7ème très
important pour du prosélytisme
comment est ce qu'on fait oui en fait
c'est ce que j'appelle les pompiers
pyromanes en face aux mets
effectivement pour l'exemple du racisme
systémique est très très intéressant
parce que c'est un exemple typique de ce
qui arrive quand on ne s'écoute pas et
quand on tire trop vite et qu'on propose
des solutions ou un remède avant d'avoir
bien poser le diagnostic
et c'est typique ce qui est arrivé c'est
que au québec au canada on a on a une
diversité de formes de discrimination il
ya la discrimination indirecte ou la
discrimination systémique qui est qui
est un effet c'est à dire que sans
vouloir explicitement exclure des gens
il ya des pratiques des pratiques
installés depuis longtemps et qui exclut
des personnes minoritaires et il ya le
racisme bête et méchant le sale noir
salle ceci salle cela et il y à là il ya
de la discrimination systémique des par
exemple les fameuses personnes qui sont
diplômés et qui ne trouvent pas d'emploi
donc les barrières systémique à l'emploi
et là les deux côtés ont été ont été
responsables
les deux pompiers pyromanes ont été
responsables du fait que cette réflexion
et cette consultation est avorté autant
le gouvernement et les politiciens qui
ont fait du millage mais qui n'avait pas
bien réfléchi et qui ont peur et qui ont
rétropédaler parce qu'ils avaient peur
que la société d'accueil se sentent en
procès et les militants est trop pressé
trop pressés de proposer une solution on
posait un faux diagnostic
ils se sont mis à voir du racisme
systémique l'on vient n'avaient pas
d'accord il ya une différence entre dire
il y a il n'y a pas la diversité n'est
pas assez représentées dans les médias
la diversité n'est pas assez
représentées dans la littérature pour
enfants etc
et dire je me fais trop poser la
question d'où tu viens
j'ai fait exprès aubert de vous poser la
question tout à l'heure de vous venez et
moi ce que je voulais savoir c'était pas
c'était je voulais savoir ce que vous
êtes
stagiaire invité au québec auquel cas je
me disais donc est-ce qu'il connaît
vraiment la réalité québécois je vais
faire attention à ne pas là le point de
proposer des exemples qui comprendra pas
mais si vous êtes québécois installé ici
je m'en fout de vous venez vous
comprenez donc donc dire à quelqu'un
d'où viens-tu ce n'est pas du racisme
systémique qui étaient installés dans
notre langage c'est parfois juste une
curiosité bienveillante
alors voilà ce qui est arrivé avec le
racisme systémique c'est qu'on a très
rapidement poser un diagnostic de racine
systémique sur des situations qui n'en
étaient pas résultat des courses tout a
été effacé et là où il ya du feu racisme
et de la discrimination
on n'en parlera pas malheureusement
malheureusement et bien mon dieu et je 1
c'est très intéressant je ne voyais pas
de cette façon moi je moi je vois que
les choses très simplement je toujours
que nous dit toujours une solution
d'avoir la charge d'un problème cela
j'ajouterai le mot précipitation dans
tout ça il ya la moe et à la fable la
précipitation se précipitent pour
éteindre un incendie
on n'a pas vu que finalement on a raté
la pharmacie et à l'aï peut-être
terminée pas la précipitation je tenais
à le dire il ya déjà des gens qui n'ont
pas lu mon livre j'ai voulu un parti qui
sont déjà en train de mais là il est ce
que je défends multiculturalisme alors
qu'il ya plein de pages dans mon ouvrage
où justement jeux pour enfants le
multiculturalisme en disant que c'est
pas une solution
alors voyez il faut prendre le temps
d'écouter quelqu'un si c'est pas la
solution
je sais que j'ai beaucoup de québécois
utilisaient utilise le terme ou le
concept d'interculturalisme culturalisme
comment vous vous naviguez à travers ça
vous oui l'interculturalisme c'est une
spéciale interculturel donc j'ai dû y
croire à un moment donné
pour mais en tous cas me définir comme
ça mais la terre culturalisme est une
voie intéressante dans la mesure où elle
est la conciliation des deux de
l'assimilationnisme à française et du
multiculturalisme à la canadienne
donc ce que j'appelle le vivre et
laisser vivre c'est le multiculturalisme
et vivre comme c'est à dire s'intégrer
dans le champ de la citoyenneté à tout
le moins
parce que dans la vie privé chacun fait
ce qu'il veut et mais le lait le noyau
de la pierre d'achoppement de
l'interculturalisme c'est qu'il faut il
ya un postulat de départ c'est qu'il
existe une ans une culture m'a dit
majoritaire la culture des francophones
et des anglophones et donc des deux
peuples fondateurs et que c'est autour
de cette culture majoritaire
francophones au québec parce que ce sont
les francophones et autour de cette
histoire commune à laquelle est venue se
greffer la révolution tranquille et à
laquelle ont participé aussi des vagues
d'immigration c'est autour de cette de
cette culture commune qu'on construit
une société compte d'abord qu'on fait le
débat interculturel et pont construit
une société interculturelle
mais il y a des objections il ya des
groupes qui est qui refuse qu'ils
récusent l'existence même d'un peuple
fondateur qui disent y'a pas ben y'a pas
de peuple fondateur
donc nous ne sommes qu'une vague une
succession de vagues migratoires qui a
commencé il ya 400 ans
donc cette majorité dont vous nous dites
qu'il faut partager les valeurs communes
c'est une vague d'immigration comme nous
sauf qu'elle est arrivée il ya 400 ans
et nous il ya quatre ans ou dix ans
seuls les peuples autochtones ont le
droit de dire qu'ils sont le sol autour
duquel cette société s'est construite
donc c'est la pierre d'achoppement de
l'interculturalisme c'est pour ça que ça
a beaucoup de difficulté à saint cerny
concrètement pour ma part je me dis même
si je suis plutôt je penche plutôt en
faveur de l'interculturalisme
je me dis quand un modèle se heurte à de
telles résistances et que ça marche pas
dans le concret c'est pas
s'acharner alors il faut trouver il faut
trouver une autre un autre angle une
autre approche qui réunisse tous a le
droit à la différence et mais pour tous
et la reconnaissance de l'existence
d'une culture quelque part qui a qui
nous a précédés cela dit je voulais
quand même préciser - ayant vécu au
canada anglais c'est ça que je voulais
demander moi c'est d'aller canada
anglais c'est la même chose si la
question culturelle du français de
l'anglais c'est sa marque une différence
oui oui canada anglais ça se vit
différemment parce que je skie ce qui
est différent au québec
c'est la question nationale c'est que
c'est pas un pays donc dès lors que dès
lors que on a essayé d'ailleurs ça a été
la difficulté de la commission taylor
bouchard la commission delors bouchard a
essayé de dire bon il ya un canada une
culture canadienne il ya le
multiculturalisme dans lequel les gens
se retrouvent ou se retrouvent pas mais
bon et au québec
qu'est ce que ça pourrait être et ça
c'est tout de suite heurtées à la
question très technique et très
juridique la citoyenneté symbolique la
citoyenneté québécoise est symbolique
elle et pas juridique
elle n'a pas d'existence juridique donc
c'est sûr que le québec a beaucoup plus
de difficultés des qui parle de culture
commune parce qu'on mette toute une
catégorie de la population qui dit de
quoi vous parlez notre culture commune
c'est le canada a un passeport les
canadiens et notre notre nos valeurs
communes c'est la charte des droits et
libertés
c'est une très très grande difficulté
c'est dans ce sens là que je parle de
majorité ça a été mal interprété ou
jeudi les québécois ont cette double
difficulté qu'ils sont en même temps une
majorité il majorité historique mais en
même temps une minorité dans un océan
anglophone donc les autres de leur
reconnaissent ni leur statut de majorité
parce qu'ils leur disent de toute façon
les autochtones étaient là avant vous
miller statut de mini leur statut de
minorité parce qu'on leur dit de quoi
vous plaignez vous avez des privilèges
donc c'est très très particulier et
nommer cette réalité là et cette
ambiguïté là ce n'est pas être
chants multiculturaliste qui dit aux
québécois vous n'existez pas et ce n'est
pas non plus être gentil immigrants qui
lèchent les bottes des québécois en leur
disant moi je vous ai compris
c'est juste c'est juste nos 1000 réalité
nouvelle réalité historique et juridique
je suis d'un fascinant vous vous écoutez
c'est que c'est encore mieux quand on
veut on la lit tout je pense que l'un
d'entre vous ou peut-être deux allez
avoir la chance aujourd'hui de lire le
livre
ok ça dépend si vous êtes bond à des
quizz ceux qui vont suivre
rachida on vous a critiqué pour ce
nouveau mot que vous avez inventé la
majorité c'est ça même si en france et
puis ici au québec acsaq à chaque fois
qu'on invente un nouveau monstre et
reprocher quelque chose c'est sortir de
les sentiers battus et personnes aiment
ça
écoutez fantastique merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
merci à vous merci merci beaucoup
vous savez c'était vraiment vous ouvrez
les pas seulement les yeux mais des
oreilles aujourd'hui ce fantastique
merci merci